Okay. But now I want to
move to the next topic. Um,
which is the topic called the
capital asset pricing model.
And it's in some points,
the high point of the class.
It's used to be the high
point of a finance. Uh,
the theory hasn't worked out as well
as people thought, uh, in recent times,
but it is quite a great achievement
and a lot of it was done here at Yale.
So I want to ex explain it to you.
So you see we have a problem so far.
If everybody's trying to hedge,
that means everybody's trying to get a
completely, you know, riskless payoff.
It's impossible because I mean,
there's real risk in the economy in s
and so how and what do we mean by real
risk?
Well,
something in one state is just going to
be bad for the whole economy compared to
another state. Maybe we'll run
out of oil or something like that.
It's impossible that everybody can
consume the same thing in every state.
So it's impossible that
everybody can perfectly hedge,
but everybody wants to perfectly hedge.
So what has to happen? What gives?
How does the theory have to change?
Well,
the theory is going to
change in a simple way,
which Shakespeare himself already
knew and already told us about.
And the merchant of Venice,
what's going to happen is everybody is
going to try and hedge as must as they
can by diversifying.
But because there's some real risk
in the economy, in some states,
things will be, uh, in the aggregate,
worse than they will be in other states.
So what's the consequence of that?
The consequence of that is if you're
going to buy an asset that pays something
that's riskless, you're going to pay the
discounted expected return of the acid.
But if you're going to
buy an asset that's risky,
you're going to need a
higher rate of return.
So the price will be less than
the expected discounted payoff.
So Shakespeare member said
exactly that. When the, uh,
the play begins with Antonio, uh,
looking melancholy, melancholy,
uh, his entire interlocutor says
Solario or somebody asks them,
it's whether he's worried about
his businesses. He says, no,
I've got a different ship. Every ships
on a different ocean. So I'm diversified.
I'm not that worried.
So Shakespeare knows about diversification
and that's what everybody should do.
But then when it comes time to pick the
caskets to get to marry the beautiful
Porsche, who by the way is not
just beautiful, but she's rich.
So they're looking for a prize,
the the uh,
but they sign a contract that whoever
picks the wrong casket not only doesn't
get Porsche,
he can never marry anyone in the future.
So what's the purpose of that contract?
It's to make it a very risky gamble.
And so why did Shakespeare want to make
it a risky gamble? So we can explain?
He understands risk and return.
So you remember the conversation
where everybody says, well,
I'm not going to pick
this unless you know,
it's only because she's so rich and so
beautiful that I'm willing to do this.
The return is so high that
it's worth the risk to me.
So Shakespeare already understood that
things that are risky are going to have
to be priced less than their
expected return. So expected payoffs,
so they expected return.
That is the payoff per dollar put into
it looks higher to compensate you for the
rest. So Shakespeare almost had the whole
story. What's missing from Shakespeare?
Well, what is the definition of
risk is missing from Shakespeare?
And it will turn out that it's going
to be a very surprising definition.
So the purpose of the model I'm going to
explain is how do you measure risk and
how should that affect the price of
things and how does that affect all the
analysis we've done so far?
Okay,
so that's the topic of the
next couple of lectures.
So the first person to confront
this problem and propose a solution,
a mathematical solution was the
mathematician Bernoulli and his brother.
So the Bernoulli's were famous
mathematical family. Uh,
and one of the brothers went off to
St Petersburg where he ended up dying
shortly afterwards, but
he invented, uh, he,
he noticed the following puzzle. Suppose
I am, some of you have heard this.
It's called the Saint Petersburg
paired Pete Saint Petersburg paradox.
So suppose I offer you a bet. I
say, ah, I'm going to flip a coin.
And it keeps flipping the
coin until it comes up. Tails.
And I count how many coin flips I've had.
I've counted until you get tails.
And if that's end flips,
you get two to the n dollars.
So if you flip it one time and
it comes up tails right away,
which is probability a half,
you get $2.
If I flip it two times and it
gets heads and then tails, okay?
That's with probability a quarter you get,
you flipped it twice,
you get to to the two or $4.
If I flip it three times and
I get heads, heads, tails,
the odds of that are half times a,
half times a half, which is an eighth.
But then you'll get two to the $3.
Okay?
So four plus eight plus,
you know,
one over two to the end times
two to the n plus dot, dot, dot.
So Bernoulli the one
who died, um, you know,
told his brother Daniel about
this and he said, well, you know,
I've offered this bet to a bunch
of people and I asked them,
how much would they be
willing to pay for this?
Risky acid and I mean,
what would you pay?
What's,
here's the numbers,
how many dollars would you
pay if I offered you this bed?
I'm going to just keep fit.
Whipping a flare. Fair coin.
Count the number of flips until a tails
and pay you to, to the end dollars.
So this is the expectation,
which obviously equals infinity.
So according to what we said so far,
you should pay infinite
amount of dollars for it,
but Bernoulli couldn't get anyone
to offer him that much money.
How much would you offer for this bag?
I just want to hear some numbers.
Dollar 50 okay.
Anybody else have any
it's pretty conservative. I mean,
that's almost ridiculous. In fact,
you're guaranteed $2 no
matter what happens, right?
So you're paying a dollar 50 and
you're going to get to for sure.
So that's a pretty
conservative number to say.
Anybody a little more
venturesome than that?
You can't do worse than $2 in this bad.
What?
$4 $4. Okay. All right.
So Bernoulli asked a bunch of people,
and the average of what they
say happens to have been $4.
That's what they said on average. And so
burdened only said, well, this is amazing.
The expectation is infinite and they're
only willing to pay me. I'm miserable.
$4 for this.
Now,
the real reason might have been that they
didn't believe Bernoulli was actually
going to pay the money. And uh, you know,
they give up their money and they
weren't going to get anything back.
But let's ignore that temporarily
and take it seriously. Bertolli said,
the solution must be that people
don't care about the dollar payoff.
They care about the utility
of the dollar payoff.
So let's put in a utility function. So
the utility of the dollar payoff would be,
you have to,
plus one porter,
you will four plus one eighth.
You have eight plus one
over two to the end.
You have two to the n plus. Dot, dot, dot.
And so then he said, well, of course,
why is that going to help? Well,
because if the utility
functions say looks like this,
so here's x and here's you a Vax,
the more dollars you get,
maybe it increases utility,
but by less and less.
So you're not really gaining much by
getting these numbers way out here.
They're not adding really much to utility.
So you only care about these
small numbers. I mean, you know,
it's good to have more, but not much
better to have more. So he said,
Lo and behold, if I put in log
natural as my utility function,
which this looks like that's
the graph of log natural. Okay.
And I put this in
and now if you know a little bit of,
okay,
now you see this is easy to solve to
compute because log of two to the end is n
times log of two. So the log of
two's come out and it's just,
the psalm is log of two times the Psalm,
one over t times the sum of
one of her two to the end,
um, times. Uh, and so it's an over to,
to the end.
So it's the,
so this is equal to log of uh,
two times the song n equals one to
infinity and over two to the end.
Yeah, that's what it turns
out. That this thing is
that,
okay,
so it's not just one over two to the n
which would have added up to one but an
over to, to the end. So the point is,
because you have the log function here,
this actually equals a log of four.
So anyway, I've worked out the arithmetic,
it's very simple. You just have,
you all know how to some
one over two to the,
and you probably don't know how
to sum in over two to the end.
You never thought of doing it before,
but the same trick gets you to be
able to some and over two to the end.
It's obviously more than one or two to
the end. In fact, it's equal to two.
So this sum is equal to two and two times.
Log of two is log of two squared,
which is log of four. So
by plugging in, instead of,
instead of caring about the expectation,
you care about the expected utility,
you can explain why the average
person was willing to pay $4.
Because the expected log in this
is equal to the log of four.
This is equal to the log of four.
So Bernoulli thought he'd
brilliantly explained his paradox.
So this is the other brother,
Daniel and the dot.
The dead brother pose the problem and
maybe solve the two for all I know,
but the one who,
the other brother who still live came
up with the a solution maybe with his
brother that it's uh, you know,
people don't look at expected payoffs.
They looked at expected utility of payoffs
and the utility should have this con
k feature that more and more
payoff ads on the margin,
less and less utility. So the,
this is, so you know what,
there's this function satisfies
d squared util effects.
The x squared is less than zero.
Second derivative is negative. Okay?
So the margin utilities declining
as you get more and more.
So that was the first, um, the,
that was the first advance on how
to deal with risk. Now actually,
Bernoulli didn't really solve
the problem because, you know,
just saying that you replace utility with
the payoff with expected utility of a
concave function,
you know,
this log wouldn't have really solved the
problem because suppose that Bernoulli
had offered instead a bet not have
to to the end. But if to, to the, to,
to the end, you know, much
more generous bet. Okay.
Then even with logs,
you would've gotten an infinite number.
So basically he should have
said that you maximize that.
People care about a concave function of
payoff where the function is bounded,
unlike log, which is
not bounded. But anyway,
let's leave that aside should
be a concave function. Okay,
so to put it another way,
a concave function has the property.
If you look at it, you know,
let's say it looks like that,
that if you have this path x a
and this path xb and you've got,
so this is the utility now
here x say,
and this is the utility, you have x
Xb and this is the utility you have.
Say if you have a 50 50
bet of either getting x,
say are getting XP, you're going to
end up with this expected utility.
Are Utilities going to be half
of Uxa plus half of your XP?
That's what we had down here.
Half of this utility plus
half of of that utilities.
I mean nothing else can happen.
Okay,
but if you're giving the person
half the amounts of money, for sure.
Okay.
Then he gets this utility which
is much bigger than that utility.
Okay.
Because this is a kind k function.
The extra you gain by winning the bet
compared to getting the average for sure
the extra you game doesn't drive the
utility up very much cause it's flattening
out. Whereas losing the bet, even though
you're losing the same number of dollars,
because from here to here as
the same as from here to here,
the loss of the same number of dollars
is more important to you than the gain of
an equal amount of dollars. And that's
why you'd rather get the middle for sure,
than having a 50 50 chance
of going on the extremes.
So Bernoulli pointed the way to
the modern theory of risk aversion,
which is to just assume
risk aversion in modern economics means
people care about expected utility.
Okay.
Maybe discounted,
expected discounted utility expected
this county utility where the utility is
concave.
Yeah.
Okay. So whatever utility
function we wrote in here,
maybe it shouldn't be log
should be something else.
How would people evaluate this?
They'd evaluate it.
Log of four and other ones they'd say
take whatever that constant utility was,
which was log of four that
produces the same utilities,
the random gamble. So this random
gamble is this expected utility,
which is equivalent to having
that for sure. So here's the four.
Okay. So La, so for,
for sure it gives it utility
Laga for that puts you here,
which is the same as the expected
utility of getting the ramp them gamble.
So that's what uh,
okay.
That's the modern theory of risk
aversion and it explains why people would
rather have things for sure.
Okay.
But it's now quantifiable because if
you can't have something for sure,
if you can't have something for sure,
then you know that it's more dangerous.
But with this concrete utility function,
you can find out exactly how much
you're willing to pay to transform.
You know,
this risky gamble into a safe gamble.
You'd give up this much expectation
in order to get the payoff for sure.
Okay. So we're going to
turn into something into a,
a vague theory into something quantifiable
and get a surprising conclusion.
Okay. So that's step one. We now think
about people maximizing utility. Well,
of course we thought about
that from the beginning.
The very first class you had utility
and diminishing margin utility.
So actually this risk aversion
with diminishing march and utility,
fortunately for us is exactly the
same thing we've been thinking about.
All along anyway, diminishing
margin, utility for consumption.
So the very assumption of diminishing
margin utility that we made from the
beginning is also
explaining risk aversion.
So it's incredibly fortunate that
we don't actually have to change.
And I have our mathematics and
we've explained a new phenomenon.
Okay?
Now the,
the most simple utility function it
needs with a log one or the quadratic.
So remember you have that
equals a plus bx minus x squared.
Okay? Now I'm on, you know,
adding a constant is never
going to change anything.
Saw,
he's going to write this
a x minus one half alpha x squared,
okay? That's going to be
my, uh, utility function,
my quadratic utility. It could be
like this, or it could be like that.
If he had a constant, you know,
which doesn't depend on x,
that's not changing what anybody does.
So that's irrelevant.
And if I divide it by a constant,
like B,
that's not going to change
what everybody does.
So I might as well as soon the quadratic
utility is x minus one half Alpha,
x squared,
quadratic tilty.
So that's about as simple as we can get
when we're used to working with those
kinds of utility functions.
Now,
why is that such a good
convenient thing for us to use?
It's because, let's suppose now
that you've got this random payoff
where with probability gamma one,
you're going to get an x
one properly gamma two,
you're going to get x to probability
gamma s you're going to get gamma s yes.
Is what's the expected utility.
The analog of renewing that means you is
going to equal summation ass equals one
to s oh yeah,
Ma
s um,
x s minus one half alpha x s squared.
Okay,
so that's all we're doing.
We're just saying that people
don't care about the payoffs.
If they have to evaluate getting x one
x two or x s they're going to take that
and multiply the payoff
by the expectation,
but not look at the payoff itself.
Look at the u, the utility of a payoff.
Quadratic is very simple.
And the reason why we're going to get
such a beautiful theory out of it is
because this number,
you don't have to keep track of all
the x's to express this utility.
We're going to be able to
summarize it incredibly simply.
This is going to equal some function,
right?
F of the expectation of x,
okay?
And the variance of x.
So all we're going to have to worry
about is the expectation of acts and the
variance of x and so many,
many very complicated things we can think
about very simply. So more generally,
if you put the log instead of the
quadratic utility,
we couldn't get this simplification.
And so the theory would have to be more
complicated. So the beautiful theory,
the capital asset pricing model comes
out of using this simple quadratic
utility. So why does it get
so simple verified? Well,
if I just write it out,
you is going to equal the
summation of gamma s ex Sas.
So this is s equals one to s.
I've let my probabilities began.
I don't know why I chose that.
Minus one half Alpha summation ass
equals one to ass of gamma s access.
Weird.
Okay,
well here we have the
expectation of x already.
Now what is this one? Fl for
gamma is excess squared. Well,
if I wrote SAS minus the expectation of x,
okay, nice. Some this squared, hey,
that's equal,
the variance of x,
that's the deaf oops times gamma
ass by definition is the variance.
But if I wrote this out, what
would I get? I get summation.
S equals one s cam,
s excess squared,
okay? Which is what I have
over there. And then I'd have,
you know what I have
minus two times summation,
gamma s excess expectation of X.
Okay?
Plus summation s equals one s of
gamma s expectation of x squared.
Okay, but what? Uh, what's this?
The second term minus two times that
the expectation of acts is a constant.
So I can take that out.
Minus two.
Expectation of x can take this out and
notice that summation gamma us access,
that's the expectation of acts as well.
So that's just minus two times
the expectation of x squared.
And this I can take the
expectation of x squared out.
My summation of the probabilities is one.
So therefore I just
get equal to summation.
S equals one to ask Amma s s s squared
minus expectation of x squared.
So therefore this up here is
equal to the expectation of X.
Okay, so what have I got here?
I've got this term, sorry,
I've got the variance of
x equals this summation,
excess squared minus
expectation of x squared.
So this term equals the variance
of x plus expectation of x squared.
So therefore I've got this minus one
half Alpha expectation of x squared plus
minus one half Alpha variance of X.
Okay? That's what the, uh, that's what the
Algebra gives me. So why is that again?
Because the given quadratic
utility up here, that thing
getting old, you have in the quadratic
utility up there, I can write it as this.
And this term, this term is
obviously the expectation of eggs,
but this term is just the variance of X.
Okay?
Plus the expectation of x squared.
So when I subtract it,
I keep the expectation of x minus
the expectation of x squared.
That's the first term.
And then I've got minus the variance
of x from that term times the one Hass
Alpha.
Okay,
so you see that depends on the
expectation of x in a positive way.
Assuming Alpha's a small number and in
a negative way on the variance of x.
So just as I said somewhere
I said it was going to turn out
like that and it did right here,
the utility is equal to the expectation
of acts and the variance of x in a
positive way on the expectation of acts
and in a negative way and the variance.
Okay, so now we're ready
to start the analysis.
We've, we've said, okay,
so far we've assumed people
only care about the expectation.
And then we said, well, we know they
don't really care about the expectations.
Hedge funds and everybody else.
If they know what they're
doing and they're trying to
keep their investors happy,
they're going to hedge.
We didn't say why they're going to hedge.
We just asserted they like to hedge so
their investors don't get mad at them.
But really what we had in mind is the
investors have some utility function.
They don't like risk. So the, so the,
the hedge fund is going to try
and keep the payoffs steady,
but there's a trade off. You know,
you can't eliminate all risk.
So how much is the hedge fund and the
investor going to suffer if all risk is
eliminated?
Now we have a way of quantifying it.
People care about the utility and
not about just the expected payoff.
And so you add more risk to them.
You replace a shore thing with a
risky thing with the same expectation.
They think it's worth that much worse.
Okay.
And so we've said that of all
the myriad of utility functions,
we could use log,
you know,
some exponential e to the
minus eight x x to the,
are there lots of different
utilities we could use?
We're going to deal with the quadratic
because it has the simple property that
in evaluating an entire risky proposition,
people care about the expectation,
which is what they cared about before.
But they're punishing themselves
for getting a bad variance.
Okay.
Okay. So because that's
such a simple thing to say,
we're going to get a simple conclusion
and a very surprising conclusion.
Okay.
So let's now analyze a problem
and see what would happen.
Okay. So the problem I'm going
to choose to analyze is this one,
I'm going to say that they're three
things can happen in the economy.
Oles with probability.
Sorry. Uh, the first three.
Anyway, those are the
probabilities. Yeah. Okay. Now,
there are many firms in
the economy, a, B, and c,
and let's say the first farm,
I don't want to invent the numbers here,
so I might as well just
write down the ones I picked.
The first one is going to be 50 or 175.
Okay.
Hey,
B,
the other firm's going to be
one 51 88 and three 65 and see,
it's going to be 300,
two 20
and 60.
And I'm going to say,
so those are the three things that can
happen and the payoff of the three firms.
And let's say there are two agents,
ancient Alpha,
uh, owns, uh,
a and also
133.5 units of x Zero K and Beta owns B
and C and I may have reversed these two
guys. Uh, okay, in 66.5
units of that zero. Okay, so here we go.
So by a Alpha and Beta,
I mean there were a million Alpha agents
in a million Beta agents and you know,
they,
you know,
so everything can be scaled by a million
because I want a bigger economy like we
always have. Okay? So there we have it.
We've got now a risky world.
Things can happen to the, okay,
so what are the utilities,
let's say utility now of
Alpha is going to equal.
So I left out the main point.
Utility of Alpha is going
to equal a half x zero.
I just made up these numbers by the
way, they're not. So summation, uh,
s equals one to three gamma s
that's the gamma s up there times x,
s minus one over 400 x s squared
the states. So there's ass
one. So here are the states.
This is state one as equals one
s equals two and s equals three.
Those are the three possible
states just like we had
before with this payoff.
And those are the payoff
of all the assets.
Oh,
Alpha ohms from a which is producing
that output in the three states and also
owns 133.5 units of x zero.
So over here,
Alpha's owning 133.5 and Betas owning
65.5 at of consumption at time zero.
So this is time zero.
This is time one
the end of the year.
So by the end of the year,
something is going to happen. There's a
lot of uncertainty between now and then.
Some of the firms are going to be paying
off in some of the states and badly in
other states and so on.
Okay.
And so the utility function for Alpha,
so he cares about consumption at time
zero and also in each of the three states.
Okay. But now he's going to
have these quadratic utilities.
He's going to say to himself,
um,
I care about my consumption and whatever
I'm going to cut. If I consumed,
if I just hung on to my AA in state one,
this would be okay if I,
if I never traded, I just hung on to a,
the utility function would be, you know,
this uh,
quadratic thing of one 33.5,
so it'll be um,
one 33.5 minus one over 400,
one 33.5 squared.
Okay. Plus, um,
he would end up with 50 minus a one over
400 times 50 squared times a quarter
plus, you know, 100 minus one over 400,
100 squared times a quarter plus 75
minus one over 475 squared times a half.
That would be as utility if he
never traded. If you just stuck
to a,
he,
he eat his own consultant in
endowment one 33.5 at time zero.
Oh that isn't true. I wrote down
the wrong utility at time zero.
I said it's time zero utilities a
half x zero. So it's a half one 33.5.
Okay, so you get a half
one 33.5 but in the future,
yeah,
he'd get this and he'd
get 50 in state one. Okay,
so a hundred in state two
and 75 and stage three.
And that's the utility he ended up with.
But that's not very good for him
because he's running this gigantic risk.
He's got this risk at time.
You know,
it's state one is a disaster for
him if he just sticks to that.
So he doesn't want to stick to that.
So how should we evaluate the shares?
Affirm a,
how should you evaluate you and all the
shares are from B when she could get,
if he gave up some of a or how
should evaluate the firm, you know,
shares a see what should he do?
Okay.
So Beta has a similar utility.
Betas,
utility you Beta
is going to equal one three quarters x
zero plus the summation s equals one to
three Ama s times x,
s minus one over 800 x s squared.
Okay. So I've made these guys far from
being impatient. They seem to, uh,
they seem to prefer a consuming in
the future till now. But, um, okay,
that was poor choice of numbers.
But lets you know the, these, this,
this number should be bigger than one
and this should be bigger than one.
But anyway, uh, I, I put a
half and three quarters. Okay.
So there's impatience built in
except it goes the wrong way.
That was just poor choice of numbers.
But the rest of it, oh, uh, you know,
expresses their risk aversion.
So Alpha is looking at the
expected payoff of what,
or he gets to consume in the future,
but he's punishing
himself by the variance.
So you look at this formula all you see,
it's not just the expectation,
but he loses something because of
the variance. And similarly, Beta,
he's looking at consumption today.
He's adding to that the expectation of
his consumption tomorrow for his utility,
but he's punishing himself for
having variance in the future.
So it's exactly what we
formalize Shakespeare's idea
of people not liking to be
exposed to variants to uncertainty,
which we've quantified by
calling variants. Okay.
Is everyone with me now? Yes, go
ahead. I'm glad you had a quick,
I just made up those numbers though.
That's the utility of Alpha
and that's the utility of Beta.
I could pick any people I wanted. I just
picked those two people. Okay. Now what?
How do they differ? Which person is
more afraid of risk than the other?
Yeah.
Is Alpha or Beta more afraid of risk?
Alpha is more afraid of risk,
right?
This one over 800 is smaller than one
over 400 so Beta doesn't really care that
much about risk. Oh cares. But you know,
it's not going to punish himself too
much by, by being exposed to risk.
Alpha is not going to punish himself too
much, but he's going to punish himself,
you know, somewhat more. So
Alpha is more risk averse.
Alpha is more afraid of risk,
it seems.
Okay.
So I've taken two agents who are afraid
of risk ones more afraid than the other,
and I've put them in an economy where
they're risky things that could happen.
And so we now have,
we not want to work out a
more sophisticated version
of pricing and EVAC will
Librium than we had before.
So let me remind you that what we sort
of have been supposing up until now is
that the price,
what would the price of a B,
if we didn't think about risk aversion,
you would so far what we would say,
what would you say the price of a is
price.
Affirm a, hey, if we didn't,
you know, if we were naive,
you might say it's a quarter, by the way,
I hope I haven't those probabilities.
Right. I didn't, you know,
it's like you'd say
it's a quarter times 50
what's a quarter times a hundred
okay.
What's a halftime? 75 is that what
you would have said? Up until now?
Even up until now, we would have been
more sophisticated than that. Discounted.
Okay. Times discounted. Okay.
That's what we've sort of figured up
until now. That's the logical thing to do.
Well,
but we ignored risk aversion
and we ignored it at our peril
because it's obviously important.
I mean Shakespeare,
a literary person,
he understood already 400 years ago
that risk aversion was important.
And their facts that
confirm what Shakespeare is.
Intuition is the stock market historically
has had a lot higher return than the
bond market. You know, even though
with the last stock market crash,
of course it came back a lot,
you know,
average since 1926 the stock markets
made something like 9% a year compared to
two and a half percent
and the bond market.
So there's a huge disparity and after
over such a long period of time,
it can't just be, it was luckier
every year after year after year,
somehow people must have realized
the stock market's riskier.
And so as Shakespeare said,
they wanted a higher return,
meaning they were playing out a
lower price, but how much lower,
how can you figure out how much lower?
So in this example, in other words,
what is the price of a,
so this is the wrong price of a apparently
because it doesn't recognize risk
aversion. Okay, so what would,
okay, so that's where
we are. So everybody,
any questions about what the question is?
We're about to give an answer,
but what do you see what the question
is that our old methodology for figuring
out prices,
um,
there's taking expectation and discounting
obviously can't be right because it
doesn't recognize risk aversion.
On the other hand,
we always had a utility function
in there from the beginning,
even a quadratic one.
So all we have to do is do what we did
before and put it in a quadratic utility
and we'll probably get the right answer.
Okay,
so that's exactly what we're going to do.
So Arrow
in 1950,
this is the same guy who proved with
the brew the Predo efficiency of
equilibrium. He was my thesis
advisor. He said, you know,
we can do the same trick that Fisher did,
so only heat.
For some reason he never credited Fisher.
I could never quite figure that out. He
had some obscure Danish guy he credited.
But anyway,
apply Fisher trick
trek and assume,
uh,
from dividends.
Dividends
are part
of a endowments.
Look
for g.
E the general lack of
Librium trading outputs,
trading, you know, trading gourds. Okay.
Then go back to find out,
then go back to deduce
value of firms.
Okay.
Okay. Now what goods are we trading
here? That was a conceptual advance.
We call them Arrow.
Okay.
And then the brew got involved to Aero De.
So de Bruin was the gale
assistant professor,
while Arrow was a Stanford
assistant professor.
So Arrow Debreu state
contingent commodities.
And so justice Fisher said an
apple today and an apple next year,
even though they're identical,
apples are different commodities with
different prices because they come at
different places in time.
In fact,
most people would prefer the apple today
to the apple next year. So Aero said,
okay.
On apple in the top state map,
when the top state
an apple in the top state is a different
commodity for the same apple in the
second state. Okay? So it
should have a different price.
So we've got to start conventional
equilibrium according to Arrow,
where as long as you have these Arrow
state contingent commodities that you can
trade trading today,
you can bond.
You can imagine today buying
an apple if state one occurs,
but not having to get the apple of state
two or stage three occurs and that will
have a price p one.
And today you could imagine buying the
apple of state two occurs a different
price from the apple of state.
One occurs and also an
apple of state three occurs,
which obviously is going to be more
expensive or it looks like it'll be more
expensive than the other apples
because it's 50% likely to happen.
And those are the prices
we have to look for.
And that's going to solve our problem
because the prices of the Arrow securities
are going to be different
maybe from the probabilities.
And that's what will reflect the fact
that when everybody's trying to hedge and
not everybody can do it, you're going
to have to change the tradeoffs.
So we've already seen this in our
gambling thing, at least the prices.
Remember with our bookies,
the bookies were effectively willing.
Remember there were two outcomes, you
know the Yankees win or the Phillies win.
And if you paid,
you know you could get the bookie.
Who thought the odds were 60 40 by
paying 60 cents today, the book,
he was going to give you a dollar if the
Yankees won are paying 40 cents today,
the book you will give you a, you
know, a dollar for the Phillies won.
So we've already had these aero contracts,
these arrows securities implicitly in
our equilibrium and those 60 40 odds,
those were the opinions of the bookie,
maybe not the actual probabilities.
We said, you know those,
the final betting odds,
depending on what the other book is,
we're willing to give it didn't
have to correspond to reality.
There might not be a reality.
Even.
So here there's a reality 25 25 50
but that doesn't mean that the odds,
the prices that are going to quote it in
the market will turn out to be that we
have to solve for echo
Librium and see what they are.
Okay.
Okay, so what's going to happen while we
can solve for echo Librium very easily.
We've done this a million times before
and I've chosen linear quadratic utility.
He's the kind we did on the very first
day of class because those are easiest to
solve for equilibrium.
You don't have to do get involved in
the budget sat or anything complicated.
You just set margin utility equal
to price. So we know for Alpha,
sorry,
we know that the margin utility of Alpha
at times zero divided by the price is
zero is going to have to equal the
margin utility of Alpha and each state as
times the price ps, so the equilibrium,
the Arrow to brew equilibrium.
Okay?
Equilibrium is going to involve p Zero p
one p two and p three the prices of the
Arrow securities,
the present value prices.
P Zero is what you pay today
to get the apple today.
P One is what you pay today to get the
apple a year from now in state one.
So these are the present value.
Present value.
That's what Fisher would say.
State contingent,
yeah,
prices. The state contingent
is what Arrow added. Now,
you may ask whether there really are
these arrows securities floating in the
economy. And we're going to
come back to that question,
but you could imagine all these Arrow
Debreu state contingent prices and
commodities, and those would be the
prices we'd solve for equilibrium.
So we get this over this
margin utility of that. Okay,
so what is this and similarly for
Beta marginal utility Beta at over
the prices,
zero equals margin utility
Beta s over the price of s.
So what is this for Alpha?
His marginal utility of
consumption is a half.
Okay. We might as well assume the
price at one of the prices is one.
Let's take this price to be one.
Okay,
so Beta her prices three quart,
her margin Tillys three quarters in the
price is one. What's his margin utility?
It's in any state ass.
It's Gamma s the Ama s times
times one.
Okay.
Minus one over 200 times x.
S
so just differentiated this.
I got one minus two over 400 times excess.
And what's her margin utility?
It's gamma s and stayed s times one
minus one over 400 times excess.
Okay.
Okay. So I know an equilibrium
that's going to imply
that
one half.
Hmm.
Well, now I have to screw around
here. So how am I going to,
so I've got this thing right
over here.
A half equals this thing over here.
What over ps.
Ah,
glad that appeared. I was getting
worried there. Thank you. Over a PS.
Okay, that helps a lot.
Uh, the whole thing.
So that implies that something like x.
So this is what Alpha is going to do
and this is what Beta is going to do.
So this implies acts Alpha s equals what?
So if I multiply through
by 200 and I bring ps over,
gam asked the other side
and I do a bunch of stuff.
I'm going to guess this is 200
minus 100 a p s over gamma ass.
How do you think that's going to play?
Right?
Peoria. Let's see if I'm
all the way through by ps.
I get from all the flights
through by ps over gamma ass.
I got ps over GAM ass times a half.
Then I multiply everything through by 200
so I get a hundred ps over gamma s and
then I get the 200 here.
So,
and the excess goes to the other side and
the ps over gas goes to the other side.
So it's 200 minus 100 ps over gamma s and
one is going to be x.
Beta s is going to equal,
well,
I'll have to do the same trick here
except the only multiplying through by 400
and taking three quarters,
which is 300 so it will be 300 minus.
MMM,
okay.
No, that was wrong. 400
Minus 300 over ps over here.
Damn man.
Okay. Because of my multiply
through by 400 put ps over Ghana,
us and the other side.
I have three quarters ps over gamma
as times 400 which is 300 ps over GAM.
As this becomes a 400 and the ps GAM
has went away. So I have that. Okay.
So I know now if I could
figure out what the prices are,
I know what everybody would
demand in every state. Okay, so
not, okay. So let me pause here. That was
the first critical step. So what did I do?
I said, it's a long story. Lot
of years went into this. I said,
people are risk averse. Shakespeare
knew that. We want to quantify it.
So we say people of concave utility
functions that quantifies risk aversion.
We want to make a simple concave utility
function. We pick quadratic, okay.
But of course we don't
know what quadratic,
different people could have different
quadratic utility functions.
Then we do the Fisher trick
and say that any equilibrium,
as long as you can buy and sell every
contingent commodity in the future,
cause the,
all the arrows securities are there,
it can always be reduced to general
equilibrium just like we did before.
And so now you have to feed the endowments
into the agents and the payoff of the
dividends into the agent's
endowments. Okay? Um,
but here, so we're going to,
we haven't done that yet.
And then we solve for
supply equals demand.
So all we have to do is we have to have
ex Alpha s plus X.
Beta s has to equal in downwind of Alpha
an s plus the endowment of Beta and
ass. Okay? But this equals all right,
so we'll have to do that for every s.
So this is a 200
minus 100 ps over GAM s equals um,
okay, now I have to do it in state one.
All right, so equals whatever they are.
So what is endowment avast and
down one of Alpha and ask Wilson,
downwind Beta vets. We have to look at
each state separately. And Lo and behold,
I picked the numbers so that
if you add these all together,
you get 500 and here you get to 80 and
two 20 is also 500 and here you get 500
again.
So Lo and behold,
there is no aggregate risk in the economy,
although the individual stocks are risky,
the aggregate is totally unrisky.
So I could pull it.
So matter what s is,
I could put in 500 here.
I'm going to turn out that the
total endowment of both people,
because I've plugged the dividends
into their personal endowments,
added up the two people.
It's 500 so it means that
ps over gamma s equals
what?
Which I have forgotten something
for sure. One Oh, x Beta.
Yeah,
so that's Alpha.
Thank you.
Glad 400 minus 300 p s over
gamma as equals 500 okay,
so if I add this up,
I get 600 um,
minus 400 p s over gamma acid equals 500
so then I flipped on the other side and
I get Pete s over gamma s equals a
corridors because 500 from here is 100 and
put the 400 and the other side
divide by it. I get ps over GAM.
I asked equals a quarter for all
tasks. Okay. So what did I find?
I found that in this
and so every,
so it's the same ps over
gamma s is the same. Okay.
Same in all states.
Okay.
So what would the price of a be here?
What's the price of a,
an equilibrium?
What's the price of a, I'm going
to take the price of a shouldn't be
price of a,
shouldn't be p one times 50 plus p two
times a hundred plus p three times 75 and
what does that equal?
Okay,
well p one is just a
quarter times gamma one,
right?
P One over gamma one is a quarter,
p two is a quarter times gamma two and p
three is a quarter times gamma three so
I just got this multiplied by a quarter.
So in fact all I did is I
did what I had always done.
I took the expected payoff and discounted
it. But discount rate is a quarter.
What's the price of the riskless asset?
Pi of one one one is just going to be
a quarter because it's a quarter times
gamble, one plus a quarter defense
gamma tube. What's the core of times?
Gamma three gamma one. Gamma two. Both
Gamma three is one. So it's a quarter.
So it implies the risk,
less interest rate as what?
What's the risk plus interest rate?
300% okay.
And that's why the disk,
so we're discounting by one over record.
Because the interest rate is 300%
so basically nothing happened.
We got all the prices exactly as we would
compute them with expect with, without,
you know, just doing expectations.
We got the right discount rate.
All we had to do was figure
out the discount. Right?
So risk hasn't played any role.
And why didn't it play any role?
Because although Alpha
started off owning a alone,
which exposed her,
I forgot who was her and who was him.
Let's say her exposed
her to a lot of risk.
She's not going to sit there
stupidly just holding a,
she's going to trade it for B and
C for different shares. In fact,
she's going to end up holding her
consumption. This is her consumption.
200 minus 100 ps over gamma's.
This number doesn't depend on s she's
going to consume the same thing in every
state by the and how can she do that?
She can own equal shares of Ab and C,
she'll own a share of the whole economy.
So in other words, by
diversifying, by diversifying,
okay.
Alpha and Beta each get rid of all risks.
So instead of calling it diversifying,
I could call it hedging.
The same thing.
She doesn't just hold her a,
she mixes BNC with it so that
she gets a payoff of consumption.
That's exactly the same in every state
because ps over gas is independent of the
state.
She'll always consume the same thing.
Everybody can hedge perfectly and
there's no problem because there's no
aggregate risks that anyone has to be
stuck with and therefore the price is just
going to be the same as the
probabilities, you know, discounted.
And that's the theory
we've worked with so far.
So so far you could say that
everything we did was kosher.
It's just that when we
had these two different
probabilities of things happening
up or down,
we thought that the aggregate economy
would have the same endowments here as it
did there. And therefore the
probabilities we used, worthy, worthy,
objective probabilities,
discounted.
No reason to change them because
nobody's going to be forced not to hedge.
Everybody will hedge [inaudible] there
any questions about what I've said?
I'm sure there should be a question cause
I can't have said it as clearly as I
ought to have. So with
somebody like to say something.
Yes.
Right.
This is the new price with the one
quarter. This is the correct new price.
So the theory so far hasn't
changed in any interesting way.
We just found the discount rate.
It just looks like expected utility.
But you shouldn't have expected it to
change because the aggregate endowment was
500 the constant in every state.
Nobody,
there's no reason why we can't have
everybody perfectly hedged and consuming a
constant in every state. And in fact
that's what we did have everybody,
she consumed the same
thing in every state.
He consumed the same thing in every state.
No reason why they both couldn't hedge
themselves perfectly and an equilibrium.
That's exactly what they did.
Okay.
Any other,
yes.
Would you create?
Okay,
so the next is going to be,
what I'm going to do now is I'm going to
assume that the endowment is don't add
up to a constant and every state
then what's going to happen.
So this is not at all obvious
how to solve this and what to do,
but it's going to turn out to have a
beautiful, simple answer. Shocking,
not only simple,
but also surprising.
So any before I do that,
I'm going to change the endowment.
So they're not all a constant. Any
questions about where we're going? Yup.
Okay.
Yes. What I Prue okay, so
thank you for the question.
Okay,
so I went a little quickly.
I said that what we proved by solving
for the general equilibrium is that the
price in every state was just going
to be a quarter times the probability.
Okay? That's what we showed had
to happen in, in equilibrium.
Now what's the consequence of that? The
consequences are twofold. Number one,
the price of all the assets is the same
expectation when I easily would have
taken before where we use the
discount rate a quarter. Okay,
so that,
and that's the first implication.
The second implication is that
from the formula for consumption,
we noticed that she consumes the same
amount in all three states because ps over
gamma ass is a quarter in all
three states for consumption.
Is going to be the same in all
three states and his consumption,
which will be different from hers,
but his will be the same in
all three states as well.
The tool will add up to 500 so then
I took a little bit of a leap and I
interpreted that conclusion that her
consumption doesn't depend on the state.
What's the interpretation of that?
She has obviously some are behind the
scenes given up some of her Aa to get BNC
and held them in a mixture, a so as to
get the same consumption in every state.
What must the mixture be?
Obviously she held the
same proportion of a, B,
and c because those add up to 500500500
so she must have held the same
proportion of a, B and c, a fraction of
the market and got a riskless payoff.
So she diversified.
She didn't just stick with her a,
she substituted a little bit of a,
a little bit of being a little bit of
see a different boat on every ocean and
now she runs no risk at all.
So she diversified.
But in the language we use last time,
I could call diversification
hedging if I wanted to.
She just sort of sold Arrow securities
in the right proportions to turn her a
into something that was
completely riskless. Okay.
So whether you call it
diversifying or call it hedging,
she's achieved the same end of totally
balancing her consumption and everybody,
he did the same thing and they both can
do it because the aggregate consumption
was a constant
yes.
In real life. Okay. The
closest we've come to an Arrow,
security in real life is a cds.
And this is part of the reason why
these economists, Larry Summers,
my classmate and Ruben who you know,
who was the secretary of the Treasury
and Ran City Corp and who was a Yale law
school student in the
Harvard undergraduate and
who I sat on many committees
with, um, he, they were seduced
by the, okay, so watts of CDs,
a CDs pays a dollar if some,
uh,
bond defaults by a dollar. Okay.
So that isn't an Arrow security,
because an arrow security's a much more
detailed thing. And Arrow security says,
I'll pay a dollar.
In state one,
an Arrow security says you get an apple
in state one, but stage one, remember,
is not described by a single firm.
State won the states of nature,
our total descriptions of everything
that could happen in the economy.
So an Arrow security really says, if
it stopped snowing in Siberia, if,
uh, the, you know, uh, Khomeini
loses power in Iran. If,
uh,
there's a favorable election
outcome and Afghanistan and uh, if,
uh, Obama wins reelection, and if a,
the u s solves the energy problem,
then I'll give you a dollar. Okay.
So the Arrow security list,
incredible number of contingent things,
every contingency possible and says,
in that case, I'll give you a dollar.
A CDs says, if this thing
happens, I'll give you a dollar.
Whether or not Obama wins election,
whether or not America discovers
a new source of energy,
whether or not Afghanistan turns around,
you know,
just as long as the bond defaults,
I'll give you a dollar.
So the CDS is an event contingent.
It's an event contingent, a lot
of event, contingent security.
That's the cds and an Arrow security.
It's a much more finely specified thing.
It's a state contingent. He, you say
everything that happens in the economy,
so we'll never get to aero securities,
but cds looks like we're
on the way to them.
And these guys blundered
by thinking since CDs is,
or on the way to aero securities,
we should have as many cds as,
and let people trade as
much as them as we can.
But we're going to get to that in the
last lecture about how all that was, uh,
you know how all this theory, what's
wrong with all the theory, but, okay,
so any other questions before we,
okay, so let's, uh, let's now,
yeah,
make the change that
he suggested up there.
Let's now change the economy just
a little bit. Let's eliminate C.
Okay. So, uh, so let's just disappears.
So obviously now the total endowment
is very contingent. It's 200.
It's 280 and it's a, what is it? Four 40.
Okay, so we now, now what do we do?
So Beta owns B.
Okay. So now what's that
delivery I'm going to be,
what do you think is going to happen?
So we're going to see,
we want to quantify this.
We want to give a beautiful,
simple theory that's quantifiable,
but what do you anticipate
happening to one p two and p three
so everybody's going to say alpha.
She's going to say, look, my a is risky.
I don't want to hold my risky thing.
I want to start hedging and
trading these arrows securities.
So I get the same constant in every
state. Of course, Beta beat Beta,
who owns B,
he's going to do the same thing.
So they're both going to be
trying to trade Errol securities.
What's going to happen
you think?
Yes.
Yeah. There's no way
that they can, exactly.
There's no way that each of
them can be perfectly hedged.
So no matter what they do, they're going
to be exposed to more risk and states,
you know,
state three is going to be a great state.
State one is going to be a terrible state.
So what do you think that means about
the prices? So there's no way to head.
Everybody can't be hedged.
And so in fact,
what'll happen is nobody will be hedged.
Okay?
Although Alpha will be who hates risk
more than Beta will be closer to hedged,
then Veda will be, um, so Beta, we'll end
up bearing more of the risk than alpha.
And what do you think will happen to the
prices of the Arrow securities relative
to the probabilities?
Yes,
there won't be a constant ratio
of a quarter as we had before,
but can you be more specific?
Exactly.
So that's what's going to turn out because
everybody though the world is short
of commodities and state one, there just
aren't many apples. That's the disaster.
That's when we, we can't solve the energy
crisis. We're totally screwed. Okay?
People, everybody wants to
consume more in that state.
Everyone's going to try and
hedge against that state.
They're all going to be trying to
buy Arrow securities in that state,
which means that because there aren't as
many divides and just not enough apolis
to go around the price of Arrow Securities
and state one is going to be high
relative to state three where everybody's,
you know, you, you know there's,
there's plenty to go around there.
So she is going to sell some of her
Aa and get some B okay to diversify,
but these got so good and state three
that all of a sudden she's not going to be
so worried about state three anymore,
but state one she's still going to be
worried about and there's nothing to be
done about that.
So the price is going to have,
have to be very expensive and state one.
Okay, so all right, that's all blah,
blah blah. Let's solve for
equilibrium and see what happens.
We can solve immediately.
Nothing's changed. The utility
functions are the same.
None of this changed. Okay, so
this board doesn't change at all.
That's demand still depends on p zero p
one p two and p three but now we have to
be a little bit more
careful and state one.
So demand in every state is 600 minus
401 over gamma one equals endowment of
Alpha plus a dominant Beta.
So in state one I'm going
to now change this to a one,
although it's my handwriting,
it looked like a one anyway.
What's the aggregate
endowment in State One?
Yeah, I agree. Getting downwind
and state one is a hunt.
It's 200 this is a one now.
Okay,
let's 200 okay,
so that means p one over gamma one
equals one right?
Because 400 and 400 so let's one so
you're not discounting the first state at
all.
You're looking at the probability of it.
But what if I go to p two over gamma
to the demand is going to be the same.
It's the price that's going to change to
make up for the fact that the supply is
much different.
Namely maybe we want to 80
yeah.
Okay. So now if I subtract,
I get 400 to 80 minus,
that is three 20 divided by 400
which looks like four fifths,
maybe two three 20 over 400 okay.
It's four fifths.
Okay. And if I go to right, because
three 20 divided by 404 fifths.
So peach over gamma twos for fifth,
they're not proportional anymore.
And then p three over a gamma three.
Okay?
Okay.
Equals now the outcome is um,
four 40
so if I subtract four 40 from this,
I get one 60 divided by 400
what's that?
Two fifths.
Thank you.
P three p three over gamma
three equals two fifth.
Okay, so a prices turned
out to be quite different.
Now the reason why they're slightly
higher on average, of course,
and they were before is because
there's less consumption in the future.
We suddenly made our
future much worse off.
So people are more desperate
to consume in the future.
So that means the price is a future
consumption. I'm going to be higher.
So we have two effects here.
These prices instead of being a
quarter everywhere are higher,
much higher than a quarter because
the future will look so much worse.
The interest rate is going to go up.
It's going to go down.
It's not going to be 300% anymore.
But more interesting is that the prices
are no longer proportional to the
probabilities. Justice,
he said over there,
the price in state one is going to be
much higher relative to the probability,
namely 100% of it.
Then the price and state three
which is only 40% of it. Okay,
so that's the conclusion.
So now what do we do for our price?
What's the price of a,
what's the price of a,
what do I plug in here? That, okay,
so that equals one quarter times 50 plus
four fifths times a quarter,
four fifths times a quarter or one fifth
times a hundred plus p three was a two
fifths times a half plus one fifth
time 75 hey would equal
something 2035 and 12 and a half.
47 and a half.
Why did I what? Okay. So what is p won?
He won is equal to gamma one.
Gamma one is a quarter. So that's
how I got a quarter here. So that's,
that's one times a corner.
Hey,
P two was to fit was three fifths.
Now what was p two maybe
I did it wrong anyway.
He too was for fifth times a quarter
times the corner.
Hey,
which is equal to one fifth and p
three was two fifths times a half.
Okay.
Okay. Which is equal to one fifth.
So that's how I got the prices. Okay,
so all right.
So you see that things change and we've
captured the idea that people can't
hedge fully by making the price of the
oral security in the state where the
economy's worse off,
much smaller than it was
before I go much higher than it was
relative to the probability then before.
Okay. So, so we haven't gotten close
to the punch line. Sorry, I got,
okay. So we're about, yes,
we're much more than you.
Okay.
So the prices,
the two things happen to the
prices compared to before.
One is that we no longer have,
the price is proportional to
the probabilities right there.
The proportion is one, four fifths,
two fists instead of the same constant,
a quarter everywhere.
And that's because the relative scarcity
people are much more worried about the
first state, then the fourth state. And
that's why relative to the probability,
the prices much higher
than the third state.
Okay.
You Fall, you agree with that, right?
Yeah.
Okay. But there's a second effect,
which is that all these numbers,
one four fifths and two FIS,
they're bigger than the quarter,
quarter quarter we had before.
But that's obvious.
That's cause we wiped out the future,
you know,
the half the endowment in
the future disappeared.
So naturally people are willing to pay
more for the future because they're poor
there. That's what we do.
In the first day of class,
we said that the interest
rate or the third week,
the interest rate according to Fisher
would go down if you've got poor in the
future. Okay. So that's part of the
reason that's happened. By the way.
What is the riskless rate of interest?
So p one plus p Plus p three
equals now it's equal to um,
a quarter plus a fifth was a fifth,
so a quarter plus a fifth plus a fifth.
These are the prices a quarter plus a
fifth plus a fifth and that's equal to,
okay,
2010, 14 over 20 okay,
so that's five over seven over 10 so
therefore the interest rate one plus r
equals 10 over seven so r
equals three seven. Okay.
Which is like 40% okay,
so the interest rate went from 300% to
40% but that's because we lost all this
future consumption,
but that's not what I'm concentrating on.
Fisher would have already known that.
What I'm concentrating on is the fact
that the prices are no longer proportional
to the probabilities. You, you're
discounting every probability,
but adjusting the probability because
people are much more worried about the
first date.
Then the third stage.
Yeah,
not a, they're more worried about
the first state at the pain.
The firms are a and B. The
states are one, two and three.
So they're much more worried about the
first state where the payoff is 200 than
they are about the third
state with a payoff.
Total dividends in the economy or four 40
you with me?
Oh boy.
That sounded so unconvincing.
So let me just say like,
I want to say the punch line.
So I've got three more minutes to go
there to punch lines, which are okay.
I haven't gotten to the
stunning conclusion so far.
I've said stuff which is um,
you know,
which Arrow and debris
had already figured out.
But now I want to go to the thing that
Tobin and Marco, it's figured out okay.
Which is one more step
we haven't noticed yet.
Arrow has already figured out that
because not everybody could hedge.
That means that the,
the,
the price of an Arrow security is
not exactly equal to the probability.
It's relatively high
if the economy's poor,
like in state one and relatively lower.
If the economy's rich like in state
three. Okay, that's common sense. Now,
what's not common sense is
the extraordinary conclusion
I'm about to show you.
Let's look at what the consumption is,
the final consumption of this.
Um,
these two people,
okay. So if we look at the final
consumption of these two people,
what's her final consumption? So
x a, okay. In the three states,
it's 200 minus 100 times one.
Okay.
Which is a hundred. What is
it? In the second state? It's,
it's 200 minus 100 times.
What was ps over times four fifths.
Okay.
Which is a help one 60 maybe.
In the last it was 200 minus 100 times,
um,
two fifths. Okay. Two fifths is 20.
So this is one 80 say that's hers.
And his consumption in the future, I'll
put a twill, I haven't talked about x.
Zero yet.
Is,
is a 400 minus 300 times one.
Okay.
Which equals 100 and here it's
400 minus 300 times four fifths,
okay?
Which is equal to help
four fifths of 300 160.
Okay.
And here it's 400 minus six no,
400 minus 300 times to fifth,
which is equal to m one
22 to 80 is this right?
Hundred hundred 60 who told me
it was 160 yes. And what's that?
Two fifths is one 20 this is two 80
what?
Which mistake is there?
Here?
Second one.
Which is this the wrong one
here?
Ford 200 minus 80 is one 20 thank you.
Okay,
so these are all right now.
Okay.
One 80 you should be. Okay. This is,
this is 40 so this should be one
60 thank you. That's it. Okay,
great.
Okay,
so now what's so shocking about those
numbers that I finally got them right.
Thank you. What's shocking is, uh,
this consumption is just the
sum of the aggregate endowment.
What's the aggregate and downwind
whenever the aggregate endowment is
just one is just a 200 to 80 and four 40
so let's say you take a quarter
of this. Okay? So the differences,
let's take a quarter of that.
That's 50 70 okay,
that's 50 70 and one 10
okay,
so a quarter of this plus,
if you add to that one 50,
you're going to get all these numbers.
So this person,
Alpha a I claim just holds
150 of the riskless bond,
pays 150 150 plus 50 7,110 that's a no,
is this the right?
Uh,
okay.
Just that's just check the number. Sorry.
Only one more second. I should have.
Okay,
so a hundred 120 and one 60,
that's the right number.
And that's equal to 50
50 of the bond plus, um,
a quarter of this thing.
So 50 50 is okay, quarter.
This is 50 70 and one 10,
right?
So if you hold 50 of the
bond plus a quarter of this,
you get 150 of the bond plus 70 is 100
2050 of the bond plus one 10 is one 60
and this guy's going to hold three
quarters of the aggregate endowment,
three quarters of the aggregate
endowment plus minus 50 the bond.
So three quarters of a,
of the aggregate endowment,
three quarters of this thing,
three quarters of the aggregate endowment
is one 50 minus 50 is a hundred.
Three quarters of this is to 10 minus 50
is one 63 quarters of that is three 30
minus 50 is to 80.
So what they've done in
ACC Librium is everybody,
despite having a million stocks to choose
from and thousands of states and all
that stuff, what everybody
does is hold the restless bond,
puts money in the bank and holds the
whole stock market. So the first day,
and we're going to improve next time,
it's called the mutual fund theorem,
which is that everybody diversifies.
Okay?
Every body diversifies.
Okay.
Hey, by holding, by holding, uh,
uh, the, the aggregate economy,
all stocks in the same
proportion plus money in bank.
Yeah.
Okay. So that fear of Shakespeare of
diversifying, what did it amount to do?
We have a very concrete thing.
You hold 10% this person's holding 50
25% of every stock in the whole economy,
plus a lendings putting some money,
$50 in the bank.
The other person is doing three quarters
of every stock in the whole economy
plus lending the money
to the first person.
So that's the first of the two
amazing results. And I'll like,
I'll start next time by explaining
it. Okay. So you're going to see,
it's going to be very concrete.